I've spent over $500,000 on my own
business education and in every single
course Mastermind coaching program
Workshop I've become the number one
student they had and then eventually
surpass the person who taught it if
you're in the game of Entrepreneurship
the game of business you have to grow in
order to get better and in order to grow
you need to learn and if you're going to
learn you might as well do it the right
way and win I had someone say this um
recently to me they're like you know how
do you know what programs to buy how do
you know what workshops to go to how do
you know what courses to listen to or
what channels to watch in order to learn
right and they're like how do you know
that it's going to work and I think
that's the question that always gets
asked is like how do you know it's going
to work and I think that fundamentally
asking that question shows that it won't
work because it is never going to be the
thing that works you are going to be the
thing that makes it work and so when I
look back at my history as a student of
and continue to be a student but student
of the game of business the I have yet
to have a negative Roi on any purchase
that I've made whether it's tutoring
courses workshops and to be fair I've
bought from from from bad people I've
brought from some scumbags I've bought
from Bad Teachers but I have absolutely
awide every single purchase that I've
made and so whenever I hear someone say
like I bought something in it and it
didn't work um it kind of grinds my
gears and I think I've had it and heard
it enough times in the last month or so
that I wanted to make this podcast about
it and so this is this is what I want to
kind of zoom out on is that I want to
give you a top- down approach in terms
of levels of competence and then a
bottom up approach from a skills
perspective and I think if you combine
both of these things together you will
make a lot more money and you will be
more successful at the things that you
try to learn and so if you're like
trying to learn how to make Tik Tok ads
to start a second you know acquisition
channel for your business then this
would apply to you if you're if you're a
customer of an agency then this will
apply to you if you're trying to be a
student and just get in the game then
this will apply you and so the first
thing is understanding the levels of
competence and so at the top the best
and the highest level of competence is
something that I will call positive
active all right so you've got you've
got the inclination and you've got
active or passive and so there's five
levels all right so the top is and and
and the characteristics of somebody who
has this belief set is that no one has
proven that it cannot be done and they
ask other people to prove to them why
they can't do it and they think I will
be the best student that this person has
ever had no matter what no matter how
incompetent of a teacher they are I will
make it happen I will win because that's
who I am not who they are basically the
idea that we make our success dependent
on the quality of the teacher puts the
power in their hands rather than ours
and so on the flip side of this the
reason that basically any single program
in the world will still be able to get
positive reviews of some sort is that no
matter what some percentage of real
winners will always go into everything
you just look at the public school
system like more or less a dog [__]
system but there are still winners that
come out of it and it's not because the
quality of the teachers it's because of
the mindset of winners because winners
will win and so the highest level of
this this example of like Elon where
he's like breaking down to physics he's
like if you can't show me that it's
physically impossible based on the laws
of physics that we know that it is
possible I'm going to go do it it's the
same concept as R Roger banister running
the first 4minute mile like no no one
had done it before and he's like well
physically it's not impossible it's not
breaking the laws of physics for me to
run a 4-minute mile and so that is
positive active now underneath of that
you've got the second class of
competence which I would consider
positive passive this is all the people
who ran the 4-minute mile after Roger
banister they're the people who say okay
he did it so I can do it and to be clear
this is still good there's still winners
absolutely that can do that and when I
look at the people that I've worked with
customers employees anything I can
identify and these are honestly these
are your these are your a minus players
like they're like okay he did it I can
do it and honestly that's a great
perspective like it's not impossible I
just need to do the same stuff they did
and that's awesome that's the that's the
replicate before you iterate they're
like I'm going to just do what they did
and get what they got and that's an
awesome perspective now there's three
more levels to this and as we go down
some of you will start nodding your
heads as either like you are this person
or you know someone who's this person
the third level of competence here is
what I'll call neutral passive and so
this is somebody who just says well it's
worked for other people let's see if it
works for me so it no longer goes from I
will like prove to me why I can't make
it work level one level two okay someone
has made it work therefore I can make it
work two let's see if it works you're
passively accepting whatever happenings
and you're just open now this is where
the majority of people are this is where
most people just sit they just live
their life passively letting things
quote happen to them and they're
sometimes mediocre customers for for for
an agency or a vendor they're mediocre
customers for you this is the person who
goes into the gym and is like we'll see
if your program works for me like I'm
you know we'll see if it works now
underneath of that you've got level four
all right this now we're going down this
is it might work for other people but it
probably won't work for me this is
negative passive so they're still in the
passive seat but they're negatively
inclined this is the person who half
asses and I'll give you a story about
this that happened recently so we had a
business owner came out I was a salon
owner okay so a salon hair salon owner
and the guy said hey I used your gift
card campaign and it didn't work and I
was like all right bro like so I just
went through it I was like did you get a
referral from all the people did you
write the name down of he's like well uh
I didn't do I mean I asked them and I
told them that they had to use the card
on other people but they came back in
trying to use the card for themselves I
was like well that's not the play he's
like well I told them that and I was
like well obviously you didn't tell them
well enough because that's not the play
so and the thing is I just let's just
stop I was like do you want me to take
accountability for the fact that the
gift card players worked for so many
businesses and just not yours I was like
do you want me to just say it's my fault
I was like would that make you feel
better and he was like well no I was
like that's what you coming for you want
me to say that it's my fault I was like
you didn't do it you didn't do it right
so you just did something else and yeah
that something else didn't work because
that's not what the program is that's
not how the gift card play works if you
don't know what I'm talking about it's
on my YouTube video it's a whole play
and So eventually it got up to be like
okay I just didn't do it I was like cool
guess what now you can do it again and
you can do it right because you know
what you messed up you had to let them
know it's for somebody else and you had
to get the referral and you had to get
the three-way introduction otherwise
they're going to trying and use it on
themselves not bringing people in and
you're just giving away services for a
discount that sucks don't want to do
that he's like okay fine and so we had a
little moment and he got over it okay
but that's negative passive that's like
it might work but it probably won't work
for me hey and by the theme if you want
to be the best student ever out of all
of mosy nation I have two books uh they
actually audio books that are for free
that I have here uh on this podcast
starting at 579 it's my $100 million
offers and $100 million leads they have
sold over a million copies 26,000 F
store views on Amazon if you like hard
copies but if you actually follow the
steps I've got courses on the site that
are also free acquisition. comom trining
if you just follow the steps prove why
it will work for you and it will now
here's the fifth level this is the
bottom of the barrel all right this is
the this is your one-star customers this
is uh this is this is the customer you
sign on who just genuinely sucks at
everything and they take an active role
all right so this is negative active I
can prove that this will work for
everyone but me I have bad luck nothing
works out for me in the end I am the
special snowflake that nothing works for
my my body is different calories don't
affect me I could starve to death and I
am immune to death because I could not
eat for years and my body would still
hold on to Fat because I am special and
so what's interesting about this is some
of you guys may be laughing about this
right now but some of you are this
person but you just might not be this
person in business you might be this
person with your weight but you're not
this way in business you might be this
way in your marriage but you're not that
way in business or you are that way in
business and you're not in your marriage
you're like oh but you know what oh this
this way of communicating it's not going
to work for us not in our relationship
but I'll prove it I'll I'll go to your
[__] sessions I'll follow your little
framework for communicating with my wife
or my husband and I'll prove to you that
it won't work because we're so special
that nothing works for us you want to
prove it and what's interesting about
this is that because underpins a whole
set of beliefs behind this that your
identity is attached to so it's so much
harder to say listen I've been fat my
whole life and and and it's my fault
it's so much easier to just not have it
be that way it's so much easier to be
like you know I've always struggled with
with women our our you know our marriage
has kind of been on the Rock but that's
kind of how it's always been that way
right and so we it's so much more
difficult to accept that all of that
pain and suffering that you've been
through is 100% your fault and so
instead it's easier to just try and
actively prove that it won't work now
there's some good there's some
interesting stuff about number five so I
actually find number five people very
very interesting because they in my
opinion have the highest potential to
jump from five all the way to one and
I've had so many experiences in my life
this is the one star becomes the five
star this is the the person that all of
a sudden like something switches and the
thing is they go from negative active
they have the active they're trying to
prove it but they're proving the wrong
thing they're trying prove it wrong but
all of a sudden sometimes if you can get
it to swap they just try to prove it
right and then they become absolute
[__] animals and so I'll tell you a
story so there was a gym owner uh at gym
launch and he was he was definitely one
of these number fives right he was like
it's not like my Gym's in a different
Market the people the people here are
different my weight loss leads are
different than everyone else's weight
loss leads my Market's different my zip
code's different the corner that my gym
is on is different but all of a sudden
he'd been on enough calls and I probably
ranted at him or something on on some on
some live call and um he was like you
basically just called me a [__] and I
was like yeah probably one one way or
another and so he said I just decided
what if what if it did work and what if
I took the same energy that I'm that I'm
doing to try and prove myself right and
try and prove this system works and what
if I just did everything as though I as
though it was going to work and I
assumed it was going to work and so he
did that and he ended up becoming one of
the top facilities out of the thousands
that we had and then we ended up hiring
him because he completely outsourced his
gym made it profitable made it make more
money using the setup that we had and
the interesting part here and this is
what's crazy same system same gift card
play Same advertising same gym model
different approach different level of
competence showed up and executed an
entirely different way I'll give you a
different example I had a lady this was
one of my first probably 50 customers at
my gym her name was Autumn so autumn
came in and she had the nothing works
for me I have a special thyroid you know
whatever uh you know if calories I could
starve myself forever and I'd still live
I defy the laws of physics and and uh
after like two three four weeks all the
people that she' started with started
losing weight and of course now normally
in that level five she'd be like well
that's of course of course that's what
way cuz I'm different than them I'm
special I get my identity from being
special and I just was like listen I was
like do you want to be right and fat or
do you want to or do you want to do you
want to get skinny I was like which one
matters more to you being right or being
thin I was like I just had I had had a
sit on with her and I was like just be
real with me if being right is more
important to you I was like then then
you can be right I was like but which
one's more important to you being right
being thin and she was like I want to be
thin and I was like then [__] do this
and so she did and of course she lost a
bunch of weight and then she became one
of my top clients and then she started
referring everyone and the thing is is
that when you see a level five turn into
a level one you're like oh my God and
the thing is they become absolute
ambassadors brand champions for you
because you help them get over that and
so I say this from a business owner
perspective because don't lose hope on
those people sometimes you just have to
say do you want to be right or do you
want this outcome I'm cool either way
but you're the one who has to live with
it
and so she decided that she wanted to be
thin which is awesome and so it's kind
of one of those it's kind of like uh
it's interesting that in like NE so
Matrix and Star Wars probably two of my
favorite um kind of universes of of of
movies um but like Morpheus and Yoda sit
in very similar positions in terms of
the guide for the for the main character
and so there's a there's a point in the
dojo where Morpheus looks at Neo and he
says stop trying to hit me and hit me
and so the the point there is that when
you it's basically the difference
between going through the motions acting
as if versus actually trying to to
succeed there's trying to do the things
that looks like success versus actually
trying to win so replace stop trying to
hit me and hit me with stop trying to
win and win stop trying to make ads work
and make ads work stop trying to hire
the sales guy and hire the sales guy
right and so it's the idea that like a
no fail situation where there there's
absolutely somebody this is like the the
founder says no one can sell like I can
sell yeah no [__] there's people who
sell way better than you right you just
haven't found them yet okay that means
that it's possible so what are you
complaining about you just need to go do
more stop trying to make your marketing
work and make your marketing work stop
trying to prove yourself right that
you're special and win it's the same
reason that Yoda says there is no
try there's only fail or do and not do
and so it's the same concept because the
reason that try is such an Insidious
concept is because it allows the
possibility of failure it basically says
that there is a way that this won't work
but if you fundamentally believe that if
like even at level two if someone else
can do it so can I then there is zero
possibility of failure because if they
can do it I will do
it and obviously the level above that is
even though no one has done it it is not
impossible and therefore I
will and so that's the that's the top
top down approach that I would approach
I said there's two levels of this in
terms of of thinking through becoming
the best student is that where are you
on that on that pyramid are you level
one are you level two level three level
four and are you in different places in
different domains are you some way in
your Fitness life or some way in your
marriage or spouse life or some way in
your in your business life and notice
how you approach it differently and then
look at the one that you're most
successful CU you're probably going to
be better hopefully better at one of
those domains than the other and think
about the thought process you have when
you approach it and use try and think
about using that set of beliefs and
systems on the one that you fail at the
most and that has been helpful for
me
now the question that I always like to
ask because obviously been I've been in
the education world and I like education
a lot is why why do we have unequal
outcomes why is it that you've got a 100
people who start and you've got one guy
who murders it one guy who tanks and
then you've got all these people in
between and so the this is the bottom-up
approach in terms of thinking about this
is the number of skills someone has
going into an
education process program whatever
predicts their success so let me explain
so if you and this this happens all the
time this is the I went through three
different things and then I did this
thing and then it finally worked but
what you didn't know is that you were
building this bridge towards an outcome
and the first thing you did gave you the
first five bricks and the second thing
you did give you the second five bricks
and the third thing you'd give the next
five bricks and then the last thing you
did just gave you the one last brick you
needed to finish the bridge across from
where you are to wherever you wanted to
go but the thing is is that we attribute
all of the success to the last brick
just because it was the most recent not
because it was the most important it's
the same thing as like it's kind of
weird in the world of like education and
business education it's like oh man I I
you know I used to think this guy was
good now I now I learn from this guy but
it's like saying yeah my kindergarten
teacher taught me uh simple Edition and
then my algebra teacher wow he really
taught me that guy who taught me you
know simple Edition is an idiot it's
like no he taught you what you needed to
get to where you're at now because
skills and education build on themselves
and so you were able to be successful
with the algebra teacher because you had
the simple arithmetic teacher beforehand
and so we have this weird thing where
you get to an advanced level and you
think that the person who taught you the
basics was somehow wrong they were just
at a different part in your process in
the stage and building the bridge and so
the reason that that that some people
are successful and you are the last
brick if you're a business owner for
that particular business is that they
were able to assemble all those skills
at a time now the more skills someone
comes in with and also the more meta
skills that someone comes in with the
more likely they are to be successful
and the reason for that is the vager the
instructions can be and so for example
someone can come to me and say hey Alex
can you build a nose strip company for
me and I would say sure because I have
that skill set to build I have all of
them right like I know how to Market I
know how to sell I know how to get
product I know how to do Logistics all
that stuff they can just say that vague
of instructions and I can go do it
because I have that skill right now that
stack of skills rather The Meta skills
you have allow you to bridge the gap
where things are vague and the vast
majority of Education basically has to
meet people at some level because if you
truly start at zero then it has to be
like here's how a computer works here is
how a phone works here is how you use
the internet right and of course most
things that you do in education aren't
at that level they're higher up than
that but the thing is is that you might
be a level four of Education here but a
level one at one of the steps and then
all of a sudden it quote doesn't work
for you but it's because you actually
are have a remedial level of education
on that step and that's where having the
meta met meta skill of like I mean as
simple as this is like shoot 30% of
people can't read good like they're just
they're not even they're not even
literate and so so of course it's going
to they're going to have a harder time
trying to learn anything because they
can't even have the ability to learn
right and so I think about this and so
if something has fed for you in the past
rather than blaming the thing blaming
the fact that you did not have
sufficient skills to make it
work and even in the most counter
example where something's Absol like
just absolute dog [__] because it does
happen right I think you can still learn
what not to do some of us had phenomenal
examples of what not to do in a marriage
from our parents some of us had
exceptional examples of how not to
parent from our parents we've had
exceptional examples of how not to boss
from our bosses we've had exceptional
examples of how not to deliver a product
from a business and so sometimes it's
using inversion thinking of like okay
what are all the things that made this
horrible and then do the exact opposite
of that and I think that that's why you
can always Roi every single experience
you have because there you can always
either benefit from it or benefit from
the inverse of it and I think both like
if you have if you have such a terrible
experience as you're like new and
innovative ways to ruin my experience
wow I didn't even know this existed well
if I can do the inverse of that then
that still will give me the benefit of
of learning from this experience I still
as much as they wanted to make me fail I
still got better like I still will win
and
so I'll I'll I'll I'll wrap this with
with a scene that I like a lot from
Invictus which is
a movie from 2006 it's Morgan Freeman
and and Matt Damon and uh Morgan
Freeman's Nelson Mandela and Matt
Damon's like the head of the rugby team
and it's right during the apartheid when
it's the whole racism is that it's you
know Max or whatever and um and he says
I'll I'll read you the quote he says
how's your ankle is it healed it's one
of the first questions he asked he's
like I heard that your your ankle you
know was hurt um you know is it healed
he asked that the head guy and he said
the truth is Sir this is Matt Damon
responding he said the truth is Sir you
never played 100% and Mandela responds
as in sports as in life and I like that
a lot I remember hearing it being like
whoa that like for whatever reason it
just hit me when when when I heard that
because we have so many times where we
blame the conditions for the lack of
success but the reality is that the
Champions create success regardless of
the conditions and so they don't look at
the education system they don't look at
the thing that the teacher gave they
don't look at what the vendor provided
and think well I'm going to prove that
they were bad so that I can be right
they just win no matter what and so I
think it's like kind of like Tom Brady
of like okay well he can go to a
different team and still go to the
championship still change the conditions
because he forces the winning to occur
and that's why like that is the like
that is the quintessential thing that
like if you look at your team if you're
a business own you're like who on my
team is a level one who's a level two
who's a level three who's a level four
who's a level five who wants to just
like prove that my thing's not going to
work who's just like we'll see if it
works who's like I think this can work
other people have done it we can do it
too and who's like we will be the first
to do it because there's no reason we
can't and I think it's a great way to to
measure and assess your team I think
it's a great way for you to measure and
assess yourself and apply it between
different domains and so I think if as I
think about these things for my for
myself um I think the the biggest thing
that I've been fortunate with um is I I
I hate the idea of someone making me
worse and I hate the idea of quote not
getting better from something I invest
time and money into and so I've always
had the desire to be the number one
person in anything that I ever try and
learn and so it's like even if this
guy's mediocre I'm going to be the best
student he's ever had no matter what
which has come to bite me in the ass
because every single person I've ever
bought something from has claimed that
they're the reason for my success but
the thing is is
that all I'm just going to get real
nasty with you I've been more successful
than every one of their customers and
them so like [__] you um and so I've
always taken it from the approach of
replicate before you iterate so I don't
try and get fancy so this is I'm
shifting gear set out because I just got
a little little passionate about this
but
like
I I will do everything they said to the
tea to replicate what they've done so if
I want to learn something from them they
have been able to do it and I will do
exactly what they did and then I can get
the same result and then once I've
replicated it then I'm like all right
here's seven ways I can do this better
than them and then I will iterate but I
think one of the other issues that
happens is people try to iterate before
they replicate and the thing is is
unless you unless you've learned to
replicate you don't know why it worked
to begin with and so you have to retrace
the steps you have to pick up the
breadcrumbs and be like okay that's we
did this because there's that hole there
okay we did this because there's that
problem there okay got it got now I have
a good lay of the land now with the
other skills that I have that the person
who taught me doesn't have I will make
this better and that's how I think you
can stair step your way learn from as
many people as you can and when you
learn by your from your third teacher
you can pull from your first and second
teacher to try and make what you learn
from the third teacher better but the
thing is is that in any of these paths
you just have to start learning and be
willing to know that no matter what
happens as long as you execute you will
learn either what to do or what not to
do but you learn either way and I think
that gives you a no fail situation as a
student because it means you become an
inevitability like I will win whether
it's with you the next guy the guy after
that I will win I will figure this out
because there's no way that this is
impossible there's no reason that
Facebook ads can work for other people's
businesses not mine there's no reason
that doing a direct mail campaign if I
can get it into the right business
owner's hands that I cannot find a way
to monetize that there's no way that
somebody else can be have a have a
billion dollar roofing company and I
have a roofing company that's only do a
million dollars a year I need to change
Industries if they can do it I can do it
there's a way and I just don't know how
yet but that's a me problem not a
universe problem and the thing that
everyone keeps messing up about this is
that they're trying to think that like
they're proving the system right or
they're proving their teacher right or
proving the guru right but you're not
doing any of that you're proving to
yourself yet again that you can win no
matter what and I think that's the big
difference because some people like
don't want to win because they want to
prove that the teacher's bad it's like
that's that's like drinking poison and
hoping the other person dies it's one of
the dumbest things I can possibly
imagine like you want to sacrifice your
outcome your success because you want to
show that someone else is bad like the
best way to show that someone else is
bad is to beat
them and then just keep winning and move
on with your life and get them to shrink
into irrelevance as you grow into your
potential